saw was not what anybody really
expected to see but right now
we're the guys talk about the
coaches you heard Chris
Collinsworth during the game say
this Titans team the defense is
playing with the attitude that
starts at their head coach Mike
Brey believes a former teammate
of yours what did he bring
tonight with his team although
my grade was fantastic I think
he should be in a call to your
conversation
think about this
he loses his very best player
they have the file to the west
coast
and they come out here and flat
out
the rams but I look at my for
able this team takes on
the personality of Rabal he's
smart he's focused
and he was a guy that works
extremely hard
I thought they played excellent
Catherine this building is stone
right now still and I don't
think they can believe it
they've been playing perfect
football for so long but for
Tennessee I just think it's
about this respect I think this
is a Baltimore dis respected
teams in all of football
the rival
is disrespected I think
Tannehill is this respect every
similar case on what was
happening in Miami Jeffrey
Simmons is disrespected I think
the Tennessee Titans are
disrespected is given this is
some team out there in
Tennessee
and everybody overlooks and they
play a horde of
defensive physical football and
they look like a team is gonna
be around for the long haul now
the top team in the AFC going
back home to Tennessee and nice
%HESITATION little cushion to
have after this victory here in
LA but Rodney you look at the
rams and what Sean McVay was
unable to do with his team in
particular in that first half
we saw some adjustments made in
the second but
where could he have coached
better in this when he got out
colds and I just thought of it
in the first half he was very
conservative everything was drop
back passes he came back
in the second half and started
doing
some hurry up offenses the
bootlegs
but to me he just didn't have
his team prepared when I saw
him in warmups I set this team
does not it doesn't look like
it's fired up Tennessee looked
fired up and I told you that
so I just I don't understand you
have an opportunity you
just signed von Miller so you
should be excited you should be
ready to run through a brick
wall and they don't do that
they just come on here lately
%HESITATION a good I'll just
really disappointed with Sean
McVay
they could block at all that was
that was a story beginning
the game Jeffery Simmons was
just blowing up every play
every passing play and you made
a good point right there I like
when they when they started
going up
star running this all fits a
little bit more up tempo you
started seeing those guys Tyrell
but this was
the beginning of the game
Simmons took over absolutely not
told
you I said Jeffrey Simmons is
the guy he's a very good player
but no one gives him enough
credit but also we talked about
the legal
all three yeah coming in
you know make it a cabin by
Kevin buyer we talked about
earlier
with nine sacks this this is a
very
disciplined team
and it's gonna be hard
to do you that they were able to
find a way to get to Matthew
Stafford they causing havoc they
he couldn't really have
any answers for the Titans
defense in this one Jack and
that's a problem when you've got
a quarterback
with the seven one team coming
into this game and he's unable
to find answers with the Titans
D. I don't remember seeing
McVeigh look this puzzle this
confused baby even
the Superbowl do you remember
the Super Bowl
L. check Superbowl game this
week this felt similar to that
you see any similar strategies
that Rabal brought out
absolutely played a lot of zone
early on and when the pressure
he pressure up the middle
and he played a lot of man to
man coverage on third down it
was basically very similar to
what coach but litigating
Superbowl similar results yeah
absolutely %HESITATION you see a
five game win streak for
the tie ins now when you look at
this team and they're rolling
at the right time in the season
Rodney how dangerous can this
Tennessee team B. as we approach
you know the second
half of the
year I mean defensively we saw
what happened all offensively
I wasn't really impressed they
have to find a way to
consistently be able to run the
ball
and we don't know what Ryan
Tannehill is we know that he's
a good athlete but can he
carried his team on his back if
he has to wrestle with the fire
and it was interesting to see
without the king everybody was
going so now all this weight
goes on Tannehill shoulder the
really was the defense
that shouldered all of that
added responsibility
you know the pick six little way
back for a touchdown and
they had the other interception
ended up at the one yard line
so the defense was creating the
scoring opportunities there
Panama Adrian Peterson making
his debut here in this game did
you notice anything from him or
yeah he looked like he was
thirty six
an old man but you don't have
any exact
and I think the body he's
playing with some of these
twenty three twenty four twenty
five year old guy so he'll get
a goal once to get the show in
there beating really talented
teams tapping up think about
buffalo handle them Kansas city
blew them out
six in %HESITATION they are
against teams are in
the playoffs last year so tell
you what this team is a good
point
it was a couple